qu'est ce que sont les élections de mi
mandat comme le nom l'indiqué c'est un
scrutin qui a lieu à la moitié du mandat
d'un président c'est une élection qui
entre autres pour but de renouveler le
congrès américain et qui évidemment a
des conséquences sur la dynamique
politique ici à washington
commençons par la chambre des
représentants tous les 435 sièges sont
en jeu
les représentants sont élus pour une
période de deux ans en ce moment les
républicains sont majoritaires
les démocrates ont bon espoir de
reprendre le contrôle de la chambre et
pour y arriver ils doivent gagner 23
sièges de plus que ce qu'ils ont en ce
moment le scénario est bien différent
dans le cas de l'autre chambres du
congrès le sénat tout comme pour la
chambre des représentants les
républicains sont majoritaires avec 51
sièges sur 100 il s'agit d'une très
faible majorité
et pourtant dans cette course les
démocrates sont beaucoup moins optimiste
pourquoi et bien chaque élection c'est
environ le tiers des sièges de sénateurs
qui sont en jeu ils sont 35 cette année
hors de ce nombre 26 sont démocrates
donc avant même de penser à des gains le
parti doit à tout le moins défendre ses
acquis et dans le cas de dix sénateurs
démocrates ils représentent des états
qui ont voté en faveur de dans notre
shop en 2016 et dans certains cas comme
en virginie occidentale ou au dakota du
nord
on parle de victoire écrasante les
élections de mi mandat c'est aussi
l'occasion pour bien les américains de
se choisir un gouverneur ou de
renouveler leurs assemblées d'état c'est
sans compter toutes les courses pour les
postes de shérif de procureur général de
mer et j'en passe ça donne des bulletins
de vote
assez impressionnant comme celui ci par
exemple
c'est donc une élection assez complexe
le taux de participation est
généralement faible
néanmoins c'est un scrutin qui est
important et peu importe les résultats
le 6 novembre ils influenceront
certainement la suite de la présidence
de dans notre genre